torcy l'espère tous défier le
républicain trump lors de la
présidentielle de novembre qui peut être
à la hauteur de ce défi l'argent est-il
le nerf de la guerre dans cette campagne
démocrate c'est l'objet de notre face à
face ce soir et pour en débattre nous
sommes avec françois durpaire historien
spécialiste des états unis régis le
sommier à ses côtés directeur adjoint de
paris match bonsoir attendait d'eux
merci d'être avec nous alors françois
durpaire vous étiez là hier soir pour
parler de l'avant un débat de michael
bloomberg très attendu bon petite
déception le débat était non non mais je
vais aussi me lever pour rider flow ils
disent dans la nuit de samedi à dimanche
à las vegas et l'événement américain
c'est le championnat du monde de boxe
les poids lourds ça a commencé hier soir
exactement s'était prêté le teaser pour
dire que ça a commencé hier soir le
match de boxe etc entre les deux entre
sanders d'un côté un matou de gauche qui
le trap abri maintenant il est il a une
avance à deux chiffres 1 32% 17% pour
bynum 14 % seulement pour michael
bloomberg
et puis de l'autre évidemment l'homme
qui valait plus de 50 milliards
eh bien ça n'a pas fait un pli c'est ko
ko technique et c'est pas des nuances de
bleu 1c on a du mal à croire qu'ils sont
dans le même parti d'un côté le
capitaliste très capitaliste et pas du
tout comme trump avec le patriotisme
économique celle-là on a vraiment
l'homme de wall street d'un côté et
l'autre le socialiste qui a été qualifié
de communiste quand même par michael
bloomberg
on s'imagine mal comment l'un va appeler
à voter pour l'autre dans quelques
semaines
ça semble assez compliqué et puis ce qui
s'est passé c'est qu'on a vu quelqu'un
qui n'était pas préparé ou qui étaient
rouillés la presse américaine utilise
beaucoup l'expression de rouille et
parce que des débats il en a pas fait
tellement et
date d'il ya quand même un petit moment
il apparaît âge il a été un peu critique
et surtout évidemment sur l'argent mais
également sur les soupçons misogynie de
harcèlement sur le racisme
vous savez la pratique dans l'état de
new york qui consiste à interpellé à
fouiller le profiling raciale ça c'est
évidemment ça passe très mal chez les
démocrates puisque il ya le poids très
important de la communauté africaine
américaine
donc c'était une catastrophe au niveau
du débat et en plus ça a été très très
suivie
donc il pourra toujours se consoler
michael bloomberg en se disant que même
si ça a été très suivi a quand même
moins d'américains qui ont vu le débat
hier soir que d'américains qui ont pu
voir c'est 400 millions de dollars
investis en pub en stratégies digitales
etc
on en parlera justement de l'argent
reste le saunier comment vous expliquer
cette piètre performance
moi je loge l'expliquent dans le sens
seul était prévisible
michael bloomberg une fait son entrée en
scène dont on sait que c'est un piètre
orateur on sait que c'est pas la
première fois d'abord qui fait ce genre
de tentatives et on sait surtout que
comme le rappelait françois il a une
assise financière qui va lui qui lui
permet déjà d'investir énormément dans
des spots publicitaires et de construire
son appareil politique pour cette
campagne
or finalement de ces débats et que c'est
là dessus plus qu il se jure je
rajouterais le le chiffon un chiffre qui
le placent nettement en tête en floride
donc ça c'est quand même des états clés
alors maintenant sur qu'est ce qui
rapproche aujourd'hui des démocrates on
peut se poser la question ce qui a été
un peu éclipsé hier à mon sens c'est
justement moi je dis qu'il ya
aujourd'hui une véritable guerre civile
au sein des démocrates guerre civile qui
ne conserve pas bloomberg bloomberg
aujourd'hui hier ça a été le punching
ball elizabeth warren
dire commencé à critiquer un
milliardaire elle a dit non ce n'est pas
donald trump ses macbook avec des mots
extrêmement durs
écoutons là et quand on la part dont
michael bloomberg doit pas être le
candidat démocrate je mène ce combat et
j'ai besoin des deux combattre son
argent après sa performance ce soir je
suis certaine que michael bloomberg est
en train de mettre la main à la poche et
qu'il est en train de dépenser 100
millions de dollars de plus pour que les
américains ne se souviennent pas de ce
qui s'est passé sur la scène du débat
des abattoirs est menacée après le débat
dans des draps elle a dit je vous
devinez un milliardaire voilà qualifie
les femmes de bronze ou de lesbiennes à
tête de cheval qui sait qui c'est donald
train non c'est lui c'est michael
bloomberg et aucune réaction de michael
bloomberg
donc évidemment oui la critique sur
l'argent c'est effectivement une
critique tous ont fait enfin c'est très
clair et ils ont dit ça c'est top c'est
à dire qu'il a dit il a dit c'est très
simple il est très très bon ce michael
ball et pour gagner une primaire n'est
pas la primaire démocrate après ma
républicaine et vous vous rappelez que
évidemment mais avec le bloomberg a
commencé sa carrière politique il était
maire de new york au départ comme ray
2015 évidemment une manière de dire il
n'a rien à voir avec nous et son
programme bricoler avec un peu
d'écologie et c'est là il était ce à
réveiller les autres ce que je sais pas
si vous avez suivi les autres débats moi
je me suis endormi il ya quelques
minutes la vigie pas endormi ça les a
réveillés tous il était électrisé par la
présence de michael bloomberg
alors tant mieux sauf que ce que dit
régis est vrai qu'à étape guerre civile
or le parti démocrate va pas disparaître
en revanche l'élection elle va
s'éloigner voici ils sont pas capables
de soutenir parce que michael bloomberg
s'est un peu
voilà le on sent que son entrée en scène
vient justement de la division qui
existe chez les autres on sent que il ya
une volonté de la part des démocrates et
d'autres personnes dans le pays de
battre à tout prix donald trump et que
michael bloomberg avec sa fortune
personnelle peut se permettre de le
faire peut se permettre d'y aller
simplement at-il les compétences at-il
le charisme il a longtemps hésité il
hésite toujours michael bloomberg
je pense qu'il sera jamais président des
états unis ça c'est mon sentiment
maintenant c'est devenu un peu hier à
mon sens piratés l'élection enfin pas
piraté perturber l'élection
une élection je reviens sur le propos
que je voulais développer c'est bernie
sanders contre les autres en fait on se
sentait bien que bernie sanders a été
l'élément qui a 4 ans a électrisé la
campagne électorale moi je me donne un
exemple personnel j'ai deux enfants de
nationalité américaine qui habitent à
los angeles qui ont 18 et 20 ans qui ont
été véritablement introduit en politique
grâce à bernie sanders et les premiers
meetings dans lesquelles ils sont allés
avant il ne faisait pas de politique ça
les intéressait pas et là il ya ce vieux
bonhomme qui est arrivé et qui est
véritablement suscité un môme un
mouvement dans la jeunesse un mouvement
dans les minorités
oui il est socialiste où il se
revendique socialiste est un gros bobo
pour beaucoup d'américains
c'est aussi ce qui fait dire à beaucoup
d'autres
d'autres américains et commentateurs qui
ne sera jamais président des états unis
parce que on est les etats unis les rues
ils n'iront pas socialiste donald trump
où il ya quatre ans on disait qu'il ne
serait jamais président des états unis
donc on peut l'aimer peut-être avoir
aussi quelque chose d'exceptionnel cette
fois ci est un combat totalement inédit
pourquoi pas son le problème c'est que
sanders
aurait sans doute battu donald trump ya
quatre ans très simplement il aurait pas
perdu puisque en site il aurait pas peur
du michigan il aurait pas tarder la
pennsylvanie il aurait pas perdu
l'ouvrier blanc et a manqué aux
démocrates il aurait gagné parce qu'il
engage pour lui ce que n'avait pas
ericsson pour le coup vous rajoutez des
propos de mélenchon est un bon analyste
politique de la situation avec à jouer
pour lui mais il avait raison il ya
quatre ans anders soirée battu donald
trump mais cette année c'est quand même
plus compliqué dire aux américains
changent et d'économie au moment au
milieu de la phase d'expansion
économique américaine la plus importante
au moins doit du siècle c'est facile
mais probablement de toute l'histoire
américaine
c'est on ne change pas une économie qui
gagne donc le meilleur candidat des
démocrates qui serait le meilleur
candidat démocrate si c'était sur le
papier ça serait michael bloomberg
parce que michael bloomberg ils changent
rien à l'économie
il a même eu il dit voilà moi je suis un
capitaliste soit la neuvième pu assumer
le voilà avec un style différent puisque
en fait dans toutes les enquêtes
d'opinion
les américaines ont un seul problème
avec donald 36 son style même si
républicains et même chez les lecteurs
de donald trump dont on dit il a
toujours sa base sa base d'aller
chercher dans sa base dans le midwest
vraiment qu'on votait pour donald trump
et ils disent ils pourraient quand même
être un peu plus présidentiel donc c'est
que ce problème de style qui se posent
la baisse d'impôts les américains sont
suis très content donc dont bloomberg
ça semble enterrée au syli parce que
c'est drôle on a vu où on a vu des
débats cybergo 100 meilleurs gardiens
nelson meilleur candidat des démocrates
saignent pour l'élection générale mais
c'est le pire des candidats pour les
primaires
il aura ni la voix des noirs ni la voix
des hispaniques ni la voix des jeunes ni
la voix des femmes ni la voix d'ouvriers
blanc parce que l'ouvrier blanc il peut
voter pour un milliardaire qui est pour
le protection pour le protectionnisme et
le patriotisme économique ne peut pas
voter pour un milliardaire quel homme de
wall street qui vient du ferry son
dernier
il est finalement le men and women
autant notre côté à new york et
authentique aussi et a su faire oublier
ça pour devenir en fait le milliardaire
des pauvres milk par et attirer à lui
des gens qui rêveraient d'être
milliardaire parce que la démarche aux
états unis par rapport aux milliards
vers l'est bien particulière en france
on voit un milliardaire en dire ou la
méfiance c'est quelqu'un il est guéri de
l'argent attention il ya toujours une
espèce de tabous catholique de fond
chrétiens contre l'argent aux états unis
pas du tout aux états unis on peut être
le plus pauvres des pauvres aient voté
pour un milliardaire en se disant le
système américain peux me permettre un
jour peut-être moi aussi de devenir
milliardaire dans cette philosophie est
totalement différente et elle a marché à
fond avec donald trump
malheureusement le style de michael
bloomberg ne passe pas et on le savait
on l'a vu à des conférences de presse
juste avant où il est extrêmement riche
extrêmement voilà il incarne un peu il
fait mieux
on a l'impression d'être dans une
wiimote du côté de wall street c'est ça
et et qui ne sort pas de ce périmètre là
et qui n'arrivent pas de sortir de ces
tours de manhattan pour aller parler au
peuple américain vous demander aux
américains les adversaires c'est i can't
truss il a été lu sur mech america great
games l'amérique et puissante à nouveau
et faisait beaucoup d'américains concept
impression là que l'amérique est
redevenu puissante que de nous parce que
il incarne il incarne donc les
américains sont pas tous à regarder la
géopolitique savoir si tant qu'il se
dise ya quelque chose qui se passe et
quels sont les adversaires des
américains les chinois
la première puissance du monde veuille
qu'on demande aux américains qui est la
première puissance du monde vous avez
plutôt la moitié des américains qui
disent et la chine d'opiacés heures
cette crainte se déclinent istres 1 1
il a gagné sur l'idée du déclinisme et
la révolte contre le déclinisme et là
vous avez un bloomberg qui vient
d'organiser sa dernière conférence sont
dans l'entreprise bloomberg lp ou à
pékin et qui a dit quoi parti communiste
chinois écoute sa population comment
vous voulez que ça me passe au sein de
l'opinion publique
il va le manger trump simplement
s'opposer aux bloomberg d'avant ça sera
très facile
il a dit par exemple dans le débat je
suis pour le salaire minimum julien et
les autres ont dit ben là oui dans le
débat mais pas avant-hier
vous avez toujours été contre donc là
vous avez un programme démocrates de
gauche et oui un ou deux vous étiez pas
sébastien pour les primaires ça sera
facile 6 millions $ en pub politique à
l'année plus d'argent pendant les trois
premiers mois et demi ne savions pas de
présidentielle c'est l'ancien président
barack obama pour l'ensemble de sa
campagne
on est dans l'ordre lors du record il
certains clips publicitaires qui ont été
déjà projeté le montre justement vous
parlez de la question du style de trump
et il a vraiment compressé mouche là
dessus c'est à dire qui montre des
extraits de tous les présidents depuis
que la télé existe en étant dans des
postures soit kennedy avec le mur de
berlin que ce soit alors on a un vrai
gars nous même george bush expliquant
les principes qui m'unissent et
américains et tous et tous et comment
ces commentaires très solennelle de ses
présidents américains qui raconte les
valeurs de l'amérique sont entrecoupées
de frasques de trump au meeting où il
dit si de toute façon si je tu es
quelqu'un sur la 5e avenue
les gens continueront à voter pour moi
des choses qui sont pas du tout
présidentielle donc ce côté justement le
style de trump il est déjà en train il
est déjà il a déjà travaillé dessus et
il va marteler ce message là après
est-ce qui va durer jusqu'à l'été je ne
sais pas c'est essayer tout va dépendre
de ce qui va se passer et ça mon avis le
super tuesday viendra parce qu'il va
rentrer véritablement au super tuesday
serra qu'on va avoir
savoir si comment électorale moyens de
peser pour ça que les autres détestent
parce qu'ils ne respectent pas la
démocratie
il a fait l'impasse sur les quatre
premiers l'état est il dit moi c'est
l'argent donc j'arrête j'y le dit
réclamant du impasse sur les quatre mois
m c'est pourquoi c'est important l'iowa
le premier est active au 2e personne
dans l'iowa
il ya personne onion chaque c'est
simplement des gens qui se disent nous
on veut être aux côtés du peuple
américain qui font des milles
une réunion s'est lui fait pas ça lui
dépensé beauty jef jël a dit une phrase
oui pendant ces il a dit quelque chose
de très fort il a dit on est en train de
se préparer un duel mortifère entre un
homme qui veut brûler notre parti et un
autre qui veulent acheter
est-ce que et celui qui habite yves
bonnet sanders adverse et ceux qui
veulent acheter
évidemment bloomberg alors les beauty
jays lui se dit avec les 10% levada donc
lui espère est une troisième voie un
quart d un changement de génération et
c'est pas encore perdu oui et ça allait
le dire est ce que on peut lui apporter
un homme mais écoutez il ya eu d
outsider
bill clinton est un beat by hilton est
arrivée quatrième dans l'iowa juste de
la nouveau moment de son élection
c'était pareil c'était le type qui
venait d'un petit village d'ain voilà
donc on ne sait pas il peut y avoir une
sorte de tout est possible dans une haie
américaine tous les candidats tous les
candidats qui gagne au final chez les
démocrates incarne un changement
générationnel et tous ceux qui n'incarne
pas s'arranger nationale à terme oui
zizou l'a dit oui c'est pas la jeunesse
qui fait le changement générationnel
les jeunes votent pour bernie sanders
est d'ailleurs de toute façon moi je
vous donne le titre
rt dimanche si the enders gagne dans des
raids à un trip titre dimanche sera
saunders peut-il être rattrapés et et je
fais le titre au site parismatch un
communiste à la maison blanche on voit
le côté dernier sandor justement qui a
remis en cause l'éligibilité même de
l'ancien maire de new york
parlons éligibilité un multimilliardaire
qui a soutenu george bush en 2004
qui a dit que nous devrions pas
augmenter le salaire minimum qui a voulu
réduire la sécurité sociale ce n'est pas
ça être éligible en baptisé l'émission
s'appelle face à face prophète on est
quand même que ça c'est si vous pouviez
se passer ce message
c'est le travail
non mais il ya aussi des face à face qui
ressorte de de l'analyse
l'argent c'est vrai que revient tout le
temps dans les critiques mais aussi
voilà de l'argent nécessaire pour
remporter cette avec attention comme je
vous disais sur les milliardaires
l'argent aux états unis et l'argent dans
la campagne électorale m'a pas du tout
même poids qu'en france on n'est pas du
tout dans les mêmes sphères
j en ai pas du tout dans les mêmes
montants parce que là vous donner des
exemples on record de ce qui est investi
par michael bloomberg de sur sa fortune
personnelle et là aussi c'est pareil
voilà un homme très très riche peut se
présenter comme ça et assommer
l'élection ou tenter de la somme et avec
sa fortune en france est inconcevable
donc attention à ces différents
justement de perception sur la question
de l'argent qui serait le mieux placé
finalement face à trump à ce que c'est
ça la question
c'est bien beau d'obtenir évidemment là
pour ça que jamais la posture la jolie
bloomberg avec cette posture là le jeu
ne change rien que du style ça serait
parfait on a une économie qui va bien
les américains veulent pas changer
d'économie veulent ils veulent rester
mais ils veulent changer de style donc
là évidemment ça serait parfait
puis attention boubers voilà quand même
oublié on est en train a dû faire un peu
un sort il a quand même dirigé 12 ans
new york qui est l'équivalent d'à corée
du sud en économique est une ville qui
est plus peuplée que 38 états américains
qu'il a une vraie expérience politique
mais évidemment senders personne peut
l'enterrer vous vous disiez un
socialiste est impossible face à donald
trump 1 ça serait quand même un débat
extrêmement interrogeable le mans
intéressant et ça obligerait donald
trump la fin de la pédagogie il n'aime
pas faire ça il devrait expliquer que le
capitalisme parce que évidemment bernie
sanders va pas dire il l'a dit
d'ailleurs c'est intéressant il s'est
entraîné bernie sanders est lui s'est
entraîné puisqu'il avait une sorte de
trump rendre grâces de lui donc il a dû
expliquer que attention il n'est pas
communiste il était socialiste mais un
socialisme
deere teintée d'écologie oui les fruits
de la croissance mais il fallait les
partager et c'est donc il a commencé un
peu à se préparer
et puis et puis ce qui est intéressant
aussi c'est que 30
ils devraient pour la première fois de
sa vie être être à contre nature de ce
qu'il est c'est là qu'il devra défendre
israël président de l'establishment
contre sanders crazy il avait il la
désigne comme que les librairies bernie
le fou et qui est crazy aujourd'hui aux
états unis s'est coincé et c'est crazy
trump c'est lui qui joue sur cette folie
en disant au peuple américain
on en a marre de l'establishment parce
qu'il ya une crise du politique votez
pour moi il a toujours pendant ces
quatre ans était à contre-courant de
tout le monde y compris de sa propre
administration parce que ça le fait
gagner et là il devra bien être
différent extrêmement présidentielle et
montrer que lui c'est la continuité et
que sanders va emmener les états unis
dans le mur dans cette crise du
politique
eh bien non c'est parce que les
américains choisiront de fer régis le
sommier comment est il perçu bernier
saunders à part parcours sans faute donc
de mes enfants parce que j'ai quand même
élan mais cette réalité des choses et
féculents
oui oui la jeunesse nous s'enthousiasme
aux pourparlers sanders et le bonhomme
qui a vécu à peu près pareil non je
crois qu'il ya une réelle charisme il ya
des idées il ya aussi des propositions
parce que bernie sanders est quelqu'un
qui est qui qui parle beaucoup aux
jeunes justement sur la question des
études et sur la question de la lane du
coût des études aux états unis qui est
un truc aussi quelque chose on perçoit
mal en france
beaucoup d'études sont quand même l'état
a ainsi dit là bas c'est pas été
exactement une partie de leur activité
professionnelle et leur vie
professionnelle à rembourser le crédit
contracté pendant leurs études et et
bernie sanders assez haut niveau de ces
thématiques lassus est extrêmement
moderne il a dessus voilà c'est ça a été
un véritable phénomène et je dirais je
rajouterais une chose aussi qu'on a un
petit peu oublié c'est la façon dont
bernie sanders d'une d'une certaine
façon a été évincé par les démocrates
eux mêmes et par l'establishment
démocrate con
voit cette fois ci à travers joe biden
et à travers quelque part des restes
finalement de 2,2 du potentat clinton
chez les démocrates
et quelque part obama un peu suivi aussi
ce moment là donc biden s'est un peu
laid le il tirait comme en voilà mais
mais mais surtout lait le lait qui
rassemble les caciques du parti
démocrate et sanders et la outsiders
c'est le mec de gauche mais mais voilà
est entre les deux aujourd'hui quand je
parlais de guerre civile c'est qu'il ya
véritablement une volonté d'aller un
contre c'est à dire une partie des
dysfonctionnements de l'iowa ont été dus
justement à d a décommandé
investissements sur des applications qui
avait été fait par des partisans d'obama
300 wii simplement ça saunders
il a effectivement pas la direction du
parti mais il a tellement reproché à la
direction du parti d'avoir joué hillary
clinton quatre ans klaes tiens quand
même à carreaux la direction et il a par
exemple les sénateurs qui se prononce
pas tellement et qu'ils sont plutôt
c'est un sénateur et les sénateurs
permettent donc il est un établissement
lui plus que greenberg en tout cas est
en tout cas on va pas essayer bannissant
des relances il veut gagner il faut
qu'il fasse une chose qui promettent sur
l'honneur aux américains ne pas
augmenter les impôts parce que eux ils
voient pas comme unis ce n'est pas une
question il se dit pourvu que ce gars-là
ne commente pas les impôts et n'abolisse
pas l'assurance santé privée comme il le
fait parce qu'évidemment le grand thème
de l'année delà de la nuit
c'était la question de l'assurance santé
mairiga
hall sur qui elle pose quand même
problème à un certain nombre
d'américains
merci à tous les deux rêviez desaulniers
françois durpaire d'avoir été avec moi